59 seconds of logos which is a red flag
that this movie don't give a fuck about
any plans I have this afternoon
reading also it's reminder reading for
those who never saw or saw but forgot
the first movie which is a lot of people
since this sequel is like 30 years late
role replicas reddit oh wow movie opens
on a human eye opening cliche awesome
such original so creativity and answer
to the question how much fog is too much
fog movie dares to answer there is no
such thing as too much fog I'm a farmer
what are you fine darkness from local to
this kitchen I prefer to keep an empty
stomach until the hard part of the day
is done what if the hard part of the day
happens at night do you go all damn day
without eating doesn't that like suck
really strong character or really few
walls you make the call also I guess
it's a requirement that I Blade Runner
movie has to open with a scene of a
character crashing through a wall cuz
she's never seen America on the contrary
dog I've seen miracle 15 times or more
oh wait you didn't mean the movie did
you and you weren't talking to me it's
2049 but guns are still firing regular
bullets where are the phasers and laser
guns and weed crack the code for AI and
naked chick billboard Holograms but
where are the photon torpedoes one
moment okay I buy all the events that
led up to the discovery of Rachel's
remains but the odds that there happens
to be a flower placed on the spot and he
catches it right before he's supposed to
be going back to base are astronomical
and I'm not gonna let that go on mention
a min and a half of K flying his ship
back to base in the rain costing jobs
casual races police officer is casually
racist talk about your overkill these
street sweepers are pretty damn hard to
miss as it is so I'm wondering if the
scrolling text and the megaphone is
really necessary also again 20:49
but we're still doing the side-scrolling
red dot matrix texting on street
cleaners whatever the fuck this large
vehicle is what caused the stagnation in
digital marquee advancement Jesus Sony
you own 50% of that long-ass opening
logo sequence you really need to squeeze
in your own obvious product placement
less than 20 minutes in movie goes hard
on this replicant racism theme in the
beginning only to completely lose that
thread over the rest of the runtime
track mmm is this movie gonna be as
obsessed with alcohol as the first one
is yes yes it is I realize it's all fake
but she just said she was trying a new
recipe then served him steak fries and
salad
none of which require a recipe whoa
this is some next-level technology now
that would that be possible
an imitator you can go anywhere you want
in the world now as long as I'm with you
and I remember to push the button on
this thing madhu kicker wait if there's
one thing this movie makes abundantly
clear about joy it's that she's ambient
and can't physically touch Kay so how
are these water drops landing on her
skin I'm so happy with you as the movie
even started yet I know we've seen 22
minutes of it but it all still feels
like not main plot stuff am Kay just had
his replica clock also this brings up a
good question
outside of the obvious sexbots why give
replicant sex organs at all I know
eventually Wallace wants them to be able
to breathe but before this point they
were built for pure subservience and
slavery wouldn't having a sex drive be
counterintuitive as we've noted many
times the power of boners is often
greater than the power of community
service go back closer closer said it's
at this point that I just throw up my
hands and realize Kay is a God in this
fucking movie sure he's super strong and
impervious to pain but he's also able to
see that no one would be able to see
even with massive magnification he was a
combat medic maybe tried to save her and
he just couldn't he didn't seem like the
same in type movie plays the pronoun
game with Deckard even though his reveal
was the most promoted part of this movie
sentimental skin job as a first-time
viewer this movie this lingo is
frustrating as hell skin job could
easily be human slang for Androids or
Android slang for humans either way
sentimental skin job would be a great
band name she was a replicant pregnant
even the Thunder knows how on - the idea
of a pregnant replicant is this is an
orgy of evidence that this is the office
of a high-ranking official that doesn't
have time for your bullshit or desk
bunches of files everywhere multiple
desk lamps hmm all were missing is a
bottle of hard liquor aha you know I
don't see any ads for Pepsi or Mountain
Dew or fresca did coca-cola finally
dominate the cola wars is it the only
option now like Taco Bell and demolition
ma'am because you've never seen a
miracle memories positional narration
and the lights came back we were wiped
clean
photos piles every bit of day tops gone
bank records 2k said the blackout was
before his time not that he didn't know
anything about it mister only saying
that for the viewers benefit my mom's
teddy cries over the lost baby pictures
well it's a shame you must have been
adorable
[Laughter]
all our memory bearings from the time
they were all damaged in the black cap
dampened seat technology has come a long
way since Harry Potter's time what can
you tell me about him
I like to work alone hey why's gap
speaking English sure things have
changed since the last movie but almost
everyone in the original spoke that
weird City speak dialect within 20 years
that went out the window you want to
show a few the new models sir before
shipment an angel should never enter the
kingdom of heaven without a gift and so
begins the obfuscating dialogue that
defines Jared Leto's character who
always seems to be reading from a
different part of the script than his
on-screen counterpart new model let us
see her that how in the name of common
sense and cost efficiency is the best
way to deliver replicate models for
Wallace's approval via giant Popeyes
wrapper okay so he's blind but he can
use the hovering sex toy drone cameras
and a chip thing plugged into his head
to see fun why the fuck does he ever not
do this
well I ever be blind if you don't have
to be a child can count to nine on
fingers we should own the stars really
feels like the only character trait
denis villeneuve gave Jared Leto was god
complex go look just because I want to
pay for sex doesn't mean I want to do it
in the storefront display window in the
future all erogenous zones will be
marked with giant asterisks maybe he's
just that good of a detective but after
sitting on the couch thinking for a bit
the piano was literally the first thing
he touched and now he's found more
evidence dude they photographed that out
of this area and there were obviously
teams of investigators sent but nobody
noticed this obvious tree carving that
was like half an inch below the dirt if
in the real world something crazy ends
up happening on 6/10 21 no one is ever
gonna stop joking about how this movie
predicted it probably all throughout
most of the 2050s a letter number is a
group of boys trying to take it away
from me so I run so now let's cut to
super specific flashback footage of this
event he barely remembers later on those
kids find me and they beat me to tell
him where it is but I don't why did this
specific memory end up in Kay I mean
what a huge coincidence that the horse
recall went to a super rep Blade Runner
what happens if I finish that should
lang get back to work madam Robin Wright
character nearly Kevin Spacey's a robot
cop why the hell is there blood out here
in the hall Coco was killed in the DNA
vault and was instantly incapacitated
was someone else murdered during the
bone burglary and they didn't feel the
need to mention it well that's an
amazing shot but isn't she
blocking his view as we've been shown
can be seen from multiple angles so Cade
be staring at the back of her head
instead of this DNA didn't like her
enough to tell her that Russ takes ten
21 this movie explores a lot of the same
territory explored by Spike Jones as her
only in this film it's a science story
rather than the focal point it's still
derivative though child the two are true
and beyond him for the rest of my life
Katy thinks he might be Rachel's son but
how would it be possible for him to be
him he's been installed at the highest
level of government then he's had his
model number verified many times the
government and Wallis corporation should
know exactly what K is
says the girl died their genetic
disorder collation syndrome she has a
syndrome named after a book of the Bible
was it a complacency called simple
sickness false idol flu how many movie
starring Harrison Ford contains
cinematic dams I mean at least two at
this point right even 30 years into the
future I'm not buying the lack of LA
traffic trash dumping spaceships borrow
the sad future imagery from wall-e
pretty damn hard well here we are the
Thunder in this movie has better timing
than Bob Newhart the ship's electronics
go out due to the harpoon including joy
but she's powered by the memory stick in
his pocket and not tied to the ship
whatsoever this is an EMP does movie
chemists read about explaining I know K
is a super duper replicant at all so I'm
not sending the fact that he survives
this but the car should be in pieces or
at the very least non-functional
[Applause]
[Music]
malfunctioning digital girlfriend damn
it I thought it was never going to say
that phrase again since this is San
Diego I'm guessing this is the de
Stoppit future of comic-con okay love ex
machina seriously I know she's been
tracking Ches movements but how do they
have this many missiles at the ready he
decides it's safe to come out of cover
even though there was a massive
firestorm just a few seconds ago and he
has no clue where it came from
if he deduced that it was from Wallace
why would he lead them to the orphanage
movie briefly cuts to live footage from
the Apple manufacturing plant okay look
I loved an evil enough and I don't mind
movies that take their time but this is
a prime looking example of a scene
taking way too long to get to the point
just get to the toy man get to the
fucking toy no one will be seated during
the Terrence Malick portion of the movie
discount holodeck if this yes wait if
Anna is Rachel's daughter and she lived
the orphanage memory then how did she
get into such a highly secured position
as the memory maker sure she escaped but
back to LA right in front of everyone
madam is calling you in they sent one
car to detain this badass super
replicate that's virtually unkillable
this is definitely a government decision
also oh I see being arrested at all as
far as Jo she knows Kay's been following
leads that pertain to the case she just
calls him in it's a certainty he'd come
you like time I could tell joy picks the
day that Kay's life is falling apart to
enact her proxy horror plan this is a
nice gesture and all but dude's got a
lot on his mind right now
also how did joy contact Mariette
without Kay knowing anyway isn't she
always in his pocket so she's real this
movie explored a lot of the same
territory explored by Spike Jones's holy
that's horrifying
also do Androids Dream of Electric
hookers it may look like he's deep in
thought right now but Kate's just
planning how to explain this threesome
to all his cop buddies luckily for the
freedom movement Kay only has the one
coat so this tracker is guaranteed to
work through the rest of the movie
they'll be coming after me soon but
instead of getting a good head start I
decided to take a break to my computer
and a pleasure bot also made some coffee
breaks antenna
wait so if love's been following Ches
every move wouldn't she know that he
went to see dr. memory were they
planning to follow up with her how about
the orphanage huh
all right but do it all slow and sexy
like how the fuck does love keep getting
into the heavily secured police station
and this movie uses a lot of cinema
since sound effects alright damn it this
movie is gorgeous and if I don't remove
a sin for this scene alone I couldn't
live with myself okay maybe I could but
I'm gonna remove it anyway
movie that was billed as Co starring
Harrison Ford waits nearly two damn
hours - Harrison Ford is a night I dream
Archie's is he talking about Hollywood
homicide also since it started happening
so often I'm gonna create a Harrison
Ford plays a character from earlier in
his career cliche no I'm not here to
take you away so deckert's plan was to
let someone he immediately suspected was
a Blade Runner get all the way into the
casino and up to the second floor before
even engaging him wait Elvis and Marilyn
Monroe existed in this universe is this
supposed to be basically our timeline
where did she go sideways then why
couldn't we get the Jerrod little
version that created replicants and
never formed thirty Seconds to Mars
he didn't even meet your own kid why
because that was the plan okay I'm
willing to believe Deckard sees some of
himself in K and K shown him that he
wasn't interested in fighting but this
information is the most closely guarded
secret ever and he's just divulging all
this because K asked him some questions
and I sure hope this punching and
kicking fest between two elite
replicants doesn't foreshadow an
anticlimactic final confrontation
between these two stop but someone
please tell me how it's possible that
joy can turn herself on here when all
the other times it's been shown that Kay
has to hit the button for her to appear
man this lady is evil how does a
replicant get such a fervent vindictive
streak god damn it
I realized that stupid movie villains
are stupid enough to leave the hero
alive but Wallace people are supposed to
be incredibly smart so what the movie
she planted that homing beacon a good
while back but somehow she what knew he
was in trouble
knew he'd found Deckard the freedom
movement had to replace a beacon but my
question is how they knew when to go
searching for we hid the child and made
a vow to keep our secret well except for
Deckard who spilled the beans within
five minutes of the first human
encounter he's had in years you imagined
it was you oh you did yes he did because
the movie told him to logic certainly
had nothing to do with it there's a bit
of every artist in their work why the
didn't she just tell him when he visited
her she cried at the memory because it
was hers why did she keep it so vague so
he would continue thinking he was real
did they threaten to take her holodeck
bubble away if she squealed sure he's
informational II challenged about his
current situation
what about Deckard makes you think he'd
just sit here and take it while some
mystery guy in the dark grabs hold of
his hands lovingly and God remember
Rachael heated her dopinder whoa how
convenient that there's a Bible verse
that matches this very specific robot
pregnancy situation you don't have
children yeah well I have millions
Travis Henry look the Blade Runner
sequel just Tron Legacy Shaun young
don't you love me eyes were green
you mean Wallace went to all this
fucking trouble to perfectly recreate
Rachel but didn't get her eye color
right that's not like missing a freckle
or something it's a very obvious trait
off-world
I have everything I need to make you
talk you do not know what pain is yet
why is the real pain torture gear all
off world though just break some glass
and start carving him up if he doesn't
talk don't no reason to go offworld Dawg
you will learn and that's it for Jared
Leto's character no return at the end no
real input into the final fight no real
impact on the movie besides the
ridiculous dialog I'm sure it's a much
more liberal society and all but is
everyone on the street right now really
looking up a giant vagina why the fuck
does the advertisement version of joy
have all black
this looks demonic as hell dying for the
right cause is the most human thing we
can do repeating intelligent sounding
dialogue as a memory just 16 minutes
after we first heard it take us back and
they hit the ocean Jesus she said take
us back turn so hard you crash us into
the ocean it takes love telling the
pilot this for him to try the engine
movie somehow manages to be interesting
for a couple hours then devolve into a
broken-down it's a small world ride I'm
probably not your son and I probably
just died trying to probably save you
from the people who probably wanted to
bioengineer your sperms face damn it is
coming down to the ultra super replicant
punching and kicking each other
repeatedly movie you're better than this
villain pulls a knife during a fistfight
cliche Deckard doesn't look as concerned
at the rising water levels as he does
boom used how many head injuries has he
had over the last few hours unkillable
villain is killed by unkillable hero who
basically had already been killed huh
this movie really could have been called
Kade a
is your problem someone set this thing
to evil I'm here for mr. Wallace I'm
love you remember your business partner
Marsellus Wallace don't you Brett I have
babies leave huge turds the world is
built on a wall you want me on that wall
you need me on that wall oh boy we were
somewhere around Barstow
on the edge of the desert when the drugs
began to take hold I had your job I was
good at it
I'm a cop I'm a good cop